[Music]
okay so I have to ask you and I hope
that you say yes are you a bit of a
royal watcher right royal family yeah a
little bit yeah so are you excited at
all about this wedding will you get it I
mean are you in LA it's gonna be like
movies in london performing for the
queen's birthday yeah so what was that
like I mean I stood next to the Queen
for about 15 minutes waiting to go
onstage but we didn't technically meet
but I was standing next to her it was
really awesome
you know um there's a lot like more
relaxed than I thought it would be in
the best way and yeah that was just
truly I mean if I'm having a really
great week and what was she like the
Queen yes she's very funny and like
every I mean the whole world family is
very normal and just like super likable
and just amazing you know did you get to
eat meet Harry and Megan I didn't I
actually chickened out I walked by the
hallway and I saw them in there and I
was like [ __ ] I say something I'm
usually and I don't freak out like that
but I was really surprised about how
nervous I got in front of them so yeah
oh man I can't believe it with that so
that's amazing so you're not going to
the wedding or oh no no I'm not going to
the wedding that would be I would see
like everyone else's well you got to
perform at the Queen exactly I mean
that's pretty darn cool yeah you're
right
[Applause]
you